John McCain he has a flawed candidate
he's wrong on the war he's wrong on the
economy everyone knows about his temper
his inability get along with people
Obama and Clinton are both extremely
intelligent they're very well educated
it goes without saying they're both very
very smart they're hard working and they
care about our country so they were both
equally qualified I came to Washington
with john mccain in 1982 I know him
pretty well I think that this illusion
that's out there is he's a great
bipartisan person is really without much
foundation he worked with russ feingold
on campaign finance reform that's nice
he's reached across the aisle in a
couple of occasions but it's been a
couple of occasions he supports the
president all of his crazy economic
policies he has supported the President
on this war the worst foreign policy
blunder in the history of the country so
I just I can't get much my juices
flowing for john mccain there are a lot
of them flowing to do everything i can
to make sure that he's not president but
i just think that he's a candidate I
repeat that's wrong on the war wrong in
the economy
her